tout le monde sait squeeze et ceci n'est
pas du tout ma vraie coupe de cheveux on
se retrouve aujourd'hui sur baby sitter
blues fait ce titre impossible à dire
sans pu sillonner bien évidemment c'est
parti vous étiez un max de gens avoir
dit au moment de sa sortie qu'il était
assez cool comme jeu et tout ça change
un peu des autres jeux d'horreur c'est
ce que nous allons voir déjà cette
musique change beaucoup de design by ped
coco va tout à la musique les béquilles
c'est fort actif avec son synthé salut
sahara on est trop content que tu as pu
venir sur os à sa bug en mon dieu j'ai
pas le temps de tout lire
laisse-moi prendre ta veste vas-y pas
trop content que tu as fuck off shore
mais c'est quoi ça vaut bien billy est
très excité de te voir
pas de problème madame johnson arrête
billy ça suffit faudra juste m'expliquer
pourquoi ses bras change de couleur
d'une seconde à l'autre genre à lâcher
blanche et lâche mitis et je suis
blanche et la suite tu devrais marqué ce
numéro 5 5 5 7 8 9 8 pour l'accouplement
brin aussi ça suffit adobe j'avais pas
vu elle est carrément bossu du français
de bonne foi
ok on doit y aller et ben dégage billy
tu arrêtes billy je vais t'attraper je
vais te rattraper je vais péter le nez
billy c'est pas bien de toucher les
cuisses au passage ben helli donc j'ai
appelé numéro comme a dit frank château
est ce que tu aimerais avoir une
réservation on est plein jusqu'à 1982
goodbye salut qu'à l'âge ou la planète
terre
quel est ce bruit haha
pourriez-vous me débarrasser de billy
s'il vous plaît merci
il me saoule ils me cassent les steaks
il aussi chelou que ce tableau kyats
mandat elle ya des tableaux de chiens
comme ça je peux ouvrir sa au hockey
c'est un dressing open it
bien évidemment c'est fermé et me
propose pas de l'ouvrir si c'est fermé
on va passer un petit film à billy
aurait trop qu'ils vont pouvoir s'amuser
à et danser comme des fous très bien
c'est pas trop possible de danser
apparemment dans jeux de pouvoir vaut
tonnes à pierce to be broken mais
attendez mais la télé cassé et comment
je fais moi je veux m'en aller
mais trop c'est le dressing t il à un
[ __ ] de bol de cheveux sur la tête
im radio john lennon aller
est-ce que ça va le bloquer you have to
find the re mind control tu peux pas
mais d'aller chercher du court partout
depuis 20 minutes
voulez vous allumez la télé à billy on
voit bien ta posture d'athlètes sitv
zone
oui le téléphone déjà téléphone yes lots
alors arrête de parler dans ta bouteille
d'eau comme baby by me protège moi il
rappelle mais votre art est elle sarah
assez jill jill [ __ ] tu m'as fait peur
hein oui quand tu oui tu viens d'appeler
j'ai jamais appelé si c'était pas toi
qui s'était assoupi vous le saviez vous
le sentiez un [ __ ] ça me plaît car on
attendait des as il se cacher derrière
moi [ __ ] d'enfants fourbe excuses
ventilateur sert carrément à rien oui
c'est fermé ça m'énerve jambes sont que
le texte là c'est un mec qui fait salut
tu veux ouvrir la porte
oh oui pourquoi pas et valence est fermé
ils sont insupportables que c'est que
cette chambre
bonjour ok donc le mec après le code de
la route à 8h30 telle étoile et elles
sont obèses vos gains c'était quoi ça
josh homme au look et une fois vie
jackson number gilad bikes made man
venir le chercher
ouais je vais t'attraper billy ok je
l'attends haut placé selon jack à
l'oreille check in 0 ol sahara est
actuellement j'ai plus de d'alcool on
peut sortir si tu en as je pense que je
peux en avoir très bien by an je sais où
aller elle était dans ce placard en or
hadjel it may sarah michelle gellar non
ton amie sarah accès cruz pour que le
peuple michel walch top col et me all
that and beach c'est moi tu traînes de
match je vais voler leur liqueurs et je
m'en vais avec mon amoureux jake open
joli corps cabinet yes c'est fermé non
ok je suis sûr que c'est ce petit bâtard
de billy qu il a caché la clé et tu vas
me dire vient la trappe et j'ai bien
joué à chiens haili est ce que tes
parents un cabinet de liqueur oui mais
tu peux pas l'ouvrir si tu n'as pas la
clé et où est la clé je te donnerai
seulement si tu le fais à manger c'est
un [ __ ] de foirer mais tué billy tuer
le tien manche ça donne moi la clé
mais pour faire la fête avec jack
voulez vous prendre la bouteille non
watts
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce serait
mieux de le mettre au lit donc le mec
d'or comme un bâton pourrait même
rajouter de bien dans sa main pour faire
style que c'est un dur lendemain de
soirée
voilà j'ai un genou jack uni j'ai juste
que tout est là je crois que sa bande
d'entrée quelqu'un sonne à l'ogs et dort
bien évidemment ça doit être jack jack
jack guez
oui tchèque le mec qui sort d'appui
sobecki kharbouchi look ou un bon joueur
je suis mal coiffé alors qu'est ce que
tu veux faire tourner le couple hugo
boss de la paix est un mec qui se tient
comme si leur bail en q2 fricadelle
c'est quoi cette tendre et qu'elle a été
brûlée bordel je prends une bière ok la
cuisine qu'est ce que c'était que ce
moyen je ne sais pas mais je vais
prendre ma bière je m'en bats les
couilles ya pas une bière prend la bière
ne ferme pas la porte où l'entrecôte si
tu préfères plus tard ok on va retourner
voir ce qui s'est passé jack bon temps
et qu'il fut là j'ai entendu un truc
dans ce backyard va regarder et si
quelqu'un est là et bien tu le défends
je veux regarder le film va regarder
maintenant très bon oeil
attendez on va suivre ça fait des gaffes
et de lire jack j'étais suis battu
regarde ou quoi mais ne me regarde pas
la porte va dedans quelque chose merde
allez va juste regarder je veux pas s'il
te plaît ok il y avait juste routière
sentiment que jack jack
à
je crois qu'il a marché sur un cloud
shit what happened to the lights et
qu'est ce qui était arrivé en direct sur
tout ça la vraie question terme et je
vois plus rien bordel déjà qu'on voyait
rien à la base
jack je vais te sauver open the door yes
tatataaa
ah non c'est la baby sitter nous avons
une tâche parce qu'elle est crédible
non ici à quoi une étagère ikea bien sûr
je vais pas me marier banon elle a plus
d'essence sa voiture de merde à eau
je pense avoir trouvé un truc bega se
crée tous et des palissades je peux la
casse et ceci est impossible ou et cette
montre toi mon enfant là bas ok jack
jack ce n'est pas le moment d'imiter un
arbre qu'est ce qui s'est passé as tu
t'es battu avec un chat annoncé quoi à
avec un tournevis vilain jacques ducrocq
tel ce qui t'as fait ça serait bien
brett watts
à temps poursuit on poursuit tient que
d'eau dubai all your fucking killing me
j'ai pas sauvegardés en bas les gens
c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo je suis
désolé j'avais pas sauvegardé j'ai quand
même essayé de refaire trois fois le jeu
et j'ai trois fois eu ce même [ __ ] de
bugs mon short de la maison et grillades
jacky près sa superbe live wallpapers a
du coup je peux pas finir le jeu
j'espère quand même que ça vous aura plu
et pour me faire pardonner je propose
tout simplement d'imiter la mort de jack
attention ça va être très intense
ciao tout le monde